hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast
I'm your host Sean Carroll for a long
time people very naturally assumed that
there was the mind the sort of
disembodied essence of what we were as
people and where the thinking happened
and then there was the body and the mind
talked to the body there weren't part of
the same thing there were two separate
entities that could somehow communicate
famously of course the philosopher and
scientist Rene Descartes really
formalized this idea of mind-body
dualism you can read a little bit about
that in my book the big picture where I
try to bring to the historical
foreground the figure of Princess
Elizabeth of Bohemia who criticized
Descartes for what we would now call the
interaction problem how in the world is
this disembodied mind is supposed to be
talking to our actual body of course
with the progress of science and our
understanding of how neurons in the
brain work we see increasingly the mind
is just a reflection of what the brain
is doing these days most working
neuroscientists are not dualists when it
comes to the mind and the brain they
study the brain to think about how the
mind is working in fact you can go
farther than that if the brain is we're
thinking happens what about the rest of
the body there are nerves and the rest
of the body in fact there are cells and
organs and so forth that clearly
influence what's going on in the brain
might it not be more appropriate to
think of the whole body as doing
cognition in some sense that's the
thesis of a movement in neuroscience
called embodied cognition the idea that
where we are thinking includes our whole
bodies not just a little brain inside
our skull there's even something called
embedded cognition which if I understand
it correctly goes and says actually it's
the whole world where we start doing our
thinking when you're writing on a
notepad that notepad should be counted
as part of your cognitive apparatus just
like your brain so I'm not so sure about
that but the embodied cognition at least
makes a lot of sense so today's guest
Lisa
Aziza day is a psychologist and
neuroscientist at the University of
Southern California here in Los Angeles
and she studies how exactly cognition
happened
in the brain and in the body for example
by putting people in functional MRI
machines giving them different tasks
watching how blood flows to different
parts of the brain and Lisa is an expert
in mirror neurons these are the
hypothesized neurons there's a lot of
evidence that they're there certainly a
lot of evidence are there in monkeys but
even in human beings we have neurons in
our brain that fire both when we do
something and when we see somebody else
do the same thing they mirror in our
brains while we see someone else doing
and these mirror neurons the theory goes
play a crucial role in not just
cognition but empathy how we understand
the motivations and the thoughts of
other people and maybe even in some
neurological diseases this is
cutting-edge stuff it's controversial
we're not exactly sure what's happening
but we'll learn a lot about it in
today's conversation we'll talk about
mirror neurons and body to cognition
more generally and a little bit about
what neuroscience has to teach us about
the process of human creativity so let's
go
[Music]
all right Lisa Aziza day welcome to the
mindscape podcast thank you it's great
to be here so we're talking about
embodied cognition right I mean there's
a lot of words that are near here like
embedded cognition and things like that
so we'll get we'll get to all that let's
just take a step back and contextualize
this right so cognition is not exactly
the same as thinking is that right
cognition is not the same as thinking so
no I would say cognition is larger and
broader than thinking so it encompasses
also emotions also subconscious
processing and so forth
and we have this you know intuitive way
of thinking about how we think like I
think I have the feeling that people are
intuitive duelists right they're they're
they're very nee Descartes right you
know they think of their mind is
something almost separate from the body
affected by it and your thing is sort of
going in the more or less the opposite
direction and you know putting the mind
more and more into the bodies that right
right so the more we learn about
neuroscience the more we learn that the
body is part of the brain you know so
all the neurons are interacting with the
body all the time and so from your gut
to the senses on your fingers to hearing
and and even though I mean the eye is
probably the most relevant because it's
so attached to the brain actually but
all of this interacts with the brain so
largely that it's really impossible to
separate processing in the brain from
processing in the body right and so
that's the philosophy behind embedded
cognition and so where did this come
from who started thinking this way um so
psychologists have been thinking about
this for a long time so there's Chalmers
there's gold performers yes that's right
George Lakoff is a linguist
who has been thinking about this also
for a long time in terms of language
processing so he talks about embodied
metaphors so how we speak with our
metaphors of the body and actions so
what does that mean yeah so things like
grasping the situation handling the
truth right so these are all embodied
ways of talking about fair
abstract things okay so as a linguist
that makes sense he's trying to think
about why we use certain visual metaphor
I guess embodied metaphor embodied
metaphors exactly and you know then
there's the newer science behind it so
there was the discovery of mirror
neurons which I think we'll talk about
in a little bit but mirror neurons were
found to be neurons that are active both
when I do something and just when I
watch someone do something so I'm not
doing anything at all but they're active
in my motor cortex as if I'm doing
something so this kind of simulating
other people's actions and then this
actually supported a lot of George Lake
Hoffs works and linguistics where we
found that when people said words like
grasping the situation or handling the
truth you would find activity in the
motor cortex okay and so this is more or
less this is where you come in right
because you're my impression you should
tell me but my impression is that your
scientific work involves poking inside
people's brains and seeing what's going
on when they're doing different things
right how do you do that so I don't
actually physically poke investigate so
we use MRI and we use functional MRI so
we put people inside the MRI scanner and
we have them do something while they're
in there and we look at the activity in
different parts of the brain so this MRI
is a gigantic thing right in someone's
lab and so they're strapped not strapped
down maybe but they're lying down and
their head is in the big donut exactly
right and hasn't there been some
controversy over how reliable fMRI are
you know sure I mean so you know every
scientific method has its problems and
MRI is a pretty gross scientific method
so you can't capture an individual
neuron your ass you're you're really
getting indirect measures of
deoxygenated blood flow so okay the
parts of the brain that use the more
oxygen are the ones that are working and
that's what you're measuring my
impression is it's good at sort of
locating things in the brain it's less
good at time resolution exactly right so
it has a lag
right um so it doesn't give you precise
timing and localization it's about you
know you can get by two by two cubic
millimeters okay and that's a lot of
neurons that's a lot of your ah yeah
okay yeah all right so let's get back to
the embedded could you help me
understand embedded cognition versus
embodied versus situated there's also
right these are all things there they
overlap largely embodied cognition is
the idea that the way that we think is
inherently rooted in our body systems so
you know if you are anxious or nervous
that's actually activity from your
internal organs that your brain is
processing ok I'm sorry so it's
literally because of your organs doing
something exactly you were feeling
anxious right not just because a certain
neuron in your brain sent a little
signal to a nearby you know so we know
from the sympathetic and parasympathetic
system that you have this large
interaction with the body and the brain
is constantly picking up information
from the body and so let's just talk
about being nervous so if you have feel
like you've butterflies in your stomach
and you're anxious that's actually
because your internal organs are being
primed by your parents by your
sympathetic nervous system and then that
information is going to the brain and
it's being interpreted as being nervous
okay so I mean I'm trying to understand
you know I've read a little bit about
this I guess where and I think it's
still controversial right the whole
thing I mean there's a science at the
cutting edge right we don't agree on
everything yet so there's it's a theory
it's a theory so there curmudgeons and
there's enthusiasts and the whole bit so
I mean there's kind of a trivial sense
in which sure my body my brain talked to
each other yeah but you're trying to be
a little bit more dramatic than that is
that right right so the idea is if you
had a brain outside of a body could it
actually process things the way we do
right and so if you believe in this
theory of embodied cognition and then
you would say no so what would it be
like me with there's a brain in the VAT
experiment right now you could put a
brain event and
electrical signals at it and you're
saying that would not be a human-like
cognition going on no I don't think so
so I think the way that we inherently
think and the way we process information
has to do with the interaction with a
body and the brain in the VAT wouldn't
be able to do it the same way
couldn't we somehow very cleverly mimic
the signals it's getting from a body you
know this is completely serious
scientists playing fun philosophical
games but right you know so the question
is could you make a computer program
that could we have enough information in
it that it could simulate a body right I
guess the question the answer is we
don't know it's theoretically probably
possible but it seems a little bit
far-fetched it does I mean this sort of
makes sense biologically right you know
I always say this one would I have
biologists or neuroscientists on the
podcast but we were not intelligently
designed right so there's not you know a
team designing the brain and a separate
team designing the body that had to work
well together the whole thing grew up
kind of organically so in some sense why
should cognition end at the boundary of
the brain right I mean the nervous
system fills our whole body exactly
right exactly and so how do we test the
extent to which that's true how do we
figure out right so a lot of the
experiments that we run look at parts of
the brain that are thought to be purely
sensory motor and we see if those
regions are involved in this kind of
higher cognitive processing okay so so
explain what sensory motor means in this
context and higher cognitive processes
process okay so there's parts of the
brain that are involved in motor control
mm-hmm so making the body do things and
it was theoretically thought before that
those regions really just only do that
they don't do much more than that maybe
they have some sensory functions as well
but not much more beyond that and more
and more we find that they're involved
in social cognition understanding other
people's intention
understanding their actions they're
involved in linguistic processing of
actions okay so language something else
that we thought was higher cognition
right and then they also might be
involved in things like empathic
processing things that we thought we
really liked the highest level of
cognition so yes so the higher levels of
cognition were thinking more abstract
thought emotions things like that
exactly as opposed to the more of sort
of unconscious things that are going on
right that's right and didn't I read in
one of his Wikipedia articles I was
looking at that it was sort of a
starting realization when we figured out
that most of the computing power in the
brain is spent on our unconscious
processes what we always think of is
automatic and and the higher cognitive
capacity is a relatively tiny amount of
our brain work yes except that you know
like the Stu vision between higher and
lower is is a tough one right it's a
fuzzy one and so I'm not sure really
where you draw the line it also like
something really interesting that's
coming out more and more now is the idea
of predictive modeling ok this so the
idea is that you know so there's two
types of processing there's what we call
bottom-up so it goes from your sensory
systems your eyes your nose your mouth
your somatosensory to the brain and then
there's top-down so that's things that
we predict will happen that we start to
already process as if they're happening
right so it's driven by the brain and
goes back down to the primary areas okay
okay and so it used to be that maybe you
know this comes actually from robotics
so what we found in robotics was that if
everything was bottom-up it would be too
slow Wow okay so the robot would be way
too slow to do anything and so we
started to do what we called forward
modeling for robots and so in there you
start to have some kind of predictive
model and the bottom-up model also sees
if it can match it and then you do some
more robust processing that way and it
increases speed okay and so we realized
the brain probably also works like
but people pretty much thought it was
about 50/50 bottom up and top down
and now more and more research is coming
out saying that the percentages are much
more toward the top down over the bottom
up and so we process things with this
kind of prediction of what we expect to
see people are giving numbers like 90
percent all right so you can quantify
this it's very difficult to quantify but
you're looking basically at information
coming from sensory systems versus
information going down from prefrontal
cortex and things like that and this is
like the classic problem of how in the
world can people catch a baseball you
know we're not doing calculus in our
head obvious exam right but somehow our
brains are predicting things and we're
judging the reality that we measure any
one time versus those predictions is
that right exactly right and so you're
saying this just goes this is the
paradigm for how we do everything in the
world it seems like it and it's um you
know it's a little surprising if it's
actually something like 90 percent right
but yeah it does seem most of the work
seems to be supporting that and I think
this has something to do again I get you
know philosophical about these things
with our perception of the flow of time
right because we're constantly so you're
saying that and maybe we can get into
the details here a little bit because it
is interesting but you're saying that we
have models of both ourselves and the
environment that we project in the
future then we're updating them all the
time exactly right I think that I've
heard people claim this is why we feel
that we're moving through time because
of this constant given take right that's
interesting I mean I think that this is
also where you know the interaction of
newer science with physics comes in
absolutely super interesting and our
what we call the present moment is
actually a few milliseconds in the past
because it takes us time to process it
to process everything right yeah so is
it one kind of map of our body that is
in our brain one little homunculus or
their different little part
doing different things there's a lot of
different parts doing a lot of different
things so for example so you have the
motor areas you have the somatosensory
areas you have auditory processing
regions even in the motor areas you have
multiple multiple Maps okay and
somatosensory areas you have multiple
maps for your internal organs you have
several maps in different parts one per
organ or several maps of each organ know
so several maps of integrated
information from Oso organs yeah okay so
we're getting information from our heart
and our liver in our lungs and that's
going to different parts of the brain
that are predicting different things is
that yeah processing it and predicting
it and you know so forth and so you
begin to see why embedded or embodied
cognition would sound like a good idea
because right right the more the more
you study it you find that there really
isn't parts of the brain that are don't
get information from the body right okay
and see and you can see this happening
your fMRI you something and you can see
something in direct evidence we would
call it yeah and how do you tell what is
it what is a very specific thing that
you would ask someone to do when they're
in that fMRI okay so you know so the
original studies and mirror neurons
we're done in monkeys so they put
electrodes inside a specific motor
neuron and they watch the monkey do
something and they see what happens when
the monkey observes someone else make
the same action in what we do that's the
analog of that and humans is we put them
in the scanner and we have them perform
an action like reach for a cup or a ball
or something like that and then what
have them watch someone else do the same
action okay and then we can go further
and have them think about the intentions
of that person or think about what that
person might be feeling when they're
doing that action something to do with a
human you can't do with a monkey that's
exactly right and then you could do
facial expressions you can have them
imitate facial expressions and things
like that and what we're learning is
that
you know the evolution is very good at
recycling right so it's using the same
part of the brain to do what we might
think of as very different tasks exactly
right
so it makes sense that in through
evolution you first probably had action
right so the brain had to do something
and then send through perception right
and that basically took up the whole
brain and as evolution progressed then
you start to use these areas for
cognition right you mentioned mirror
mirror neurons a couple of times let's
just admit that we should talk about
what these are that tell us what a
mirror neuron is is like how many of
them are is that they particularly place
in the brain where we find them yeah so
mirror neurons were discovered in
monkeys they were discovered in monkey
area five which is equivalent to the
premotor cortex in humans and then fear
frontal gyrus as well and they were
found to be active so using single-cell
electrodes they that were inserted into
this area of the monkey brain they were
they found that these neurons are active
when the monkey does something as well
as when the monkey sees someone making
the same action okay and this was when
when are we talking about 96 oh that
recently yes and this was by rizzolatti
slab in Parma Italy uh-huh and so the
same neurons I mean again is it even
possible to ask how many neurons were
talking about no no it's it's quite a
lot and it's you know the same brain
region so this at five brain region has
it's a mosaic so there some your neurons
there there's other kinds of neurons
there and so forth and there's like
eighty-five billion neurons in the brain
so there's probably a whole bunch that
are doing yes and it but it really is
but you know how specialized our neurons
I mean they're localized in different
parts of the brain where there are the
actual neurons and one part of the brain
different than neurons and other parts
of the brain yes so mirror neurons are
specifically motor neurons so there are
really only in motor areas so we they've
been found now in the parietal cortex as
well as in this promoter area and then
you'll find you know visual neurons and
that
parts and so forth right so we
discovered them in monkeys there's the
lunar on that does the same thing if the
monkeys doing something and see someone
else do it
and we're not allowed to cut open human
beings skulls and my electorate put
electric signals in there so it's harder
to test this for human beings but it
would make sense right right so the way
that we do it is by using something like
fMRI you could also use eg TMS
transcranial magnetic stimulation has
also been used so there's all these
indirect measures and this is something
that we think has to do with not I mean
okay what is the point why do these
mirror neurons do this so fine I see you
know I pick up a cup of some neurons
fire I see you pick up a cup the same
neurons fire in my brain what's up with
that
okay so then this is where the theory
comes in right yes okay so there's a
bunch of different theories so one very
basic one is that it's involved in
processing other people's actions very
that's a sort of the most simple one
right and then there's theories of
simulation that the way I understand you
the way I understand what you're doing
the way I understand when you reach for
a cup that means that you're probably
thirsty is by simulating I know that
when I reach for a cop that's because
I'm thirsty
and so if my motor regions are
simulating unconsciously what you're
doing at every moment then I have an
understanding of your experience so it
helps me have a theory of your mind if I
can sort of simulate it exactly so it's
like the simulation hypothesis is like
everything is just a little simulation
in my brain exactly right right and
you're doing this you know constantly
with because there you're not there's
not just one person in front of you but
there's a lot of people doing a lot of
things so you there's a lot to keep
track of right and is that so I keep
going back and forth between this but so
we do an experiment and learn that the
neurons are mirroring and then we invent
a theory that says this helps us
understand other people's brains so how
do we test that theory right so there's
different ways so you just design
for experiments to try to get at what's
the difference between understanding
someone's intention versus understanding
the context of a scene of versus
understanding reaching without actually
picking up a cup right and you could
look at brain differences for mirror
neurons or what you think are mirror
neurons for each of those scenarios and
compare activity levels is there an
example of a clever experiment you can
think of yeah so so actually one of them
comes from rizzolatti slab where he's
he's actually doing this in the monkey
and so he has the monkey reach for an
apple okay and then he has the monkey
watch an experimenter reach for the
Apple and then he has an occluded
scenario where he at the moment where
the grasp to the Apple is going to
happen there's a screen put on that the
monkey can no longer see if the Apple
was there or not okay and so now there's
just a grasp but there's no object that
the monkey sees but the monkey saw
previously that the Apple was there so
he has to infer right and so you find
that the mirror neurons are still active
okay okay but if the Apple was not there
and the person grasped for it then the
monk then mirror neurons no longer
activate oh okay so you know the person
is doing the same thing exact action
because it has a different meaning yes
does it not grasping for something yes
these neurons don't fire right and so
from this the RIT Salada group infers
that the intention of the goal is very
important for these neurons right so
you're actually processing intentions
good so that yet another reminder that
you know the way the neurons represent
the world is not just it's a picture of
the world is this complicated thing
where there's meanings and intentions
goals and goals and purposes oh yeah
yeah does this teach us much about human
psychology you think sure so I think you
know so I think that we're always trying
to understand other people's intentions
and trying to understand the underlying
meaning of their actions and so it could
be that these neurons and humans are
also involved in doing that
so that's where empathy comes in for
example so do you study empathy for this
reason I do so we also find that people
who score high on trait empathy measures
of empathy they actually show more
activity in these mirror regions okay is
it something to be said about people who
don't show any activity yes so you know
we find that so I also study individuals
with autism okay and so we actually show
that they have less activity in these
regions and some of some people with
autism also have lower empathic
processing and difficulty with social
processing in general it's a bikini miss
function in autism you also find this
you know there's so empathy is
complicated there's different kinds of
empathy
so psychologists generally divide
empathy into three components
okay so there's sympathy which is kind
of mentalizing is what we would call it
where you're thinking about someone's
actions and intentions and feelings but
in a very abstract way right okay okay
so I'm not like identifying with you as
a person but I'm sort of getting this
idea what you're thinking yeah I mean
the best example I can give of this is
if you're in a relationship and your
partner's really upset with you and
you're having a really hard time getting
for but they explain it more and more
and you're kind of like in this abstract
realm you're like okay kind of
understand why you're upset with me
intellectually intellectually yes I
would never respond that way myself
right but I was called sympathy that's
not sympathy all right sounds like weird
sympathy okay so it's a very cognitive
form of empathy and very abstract okay
okay then we have empathy which is
sharing someone's feelings so here I
feel exactly what you feel so if you're
in pain
I actually feel that pain myself
literally feel it yeah literally feel it
okay and then there's compassion and
compassion is proactive behavior where
you actually want to do something to
help the person so not only do you feel
but you feel compassion for them and you
want to do something to help them and a
beautiful feeling of warmth for the
other person
I would guess all three of these are
separate right like I have compassion
even if I don't feel exactly exactly so
first of all there are three different
networks in the brain okay so we can map
these out mm-hmm and then there's
different disorders that you know so
someone could so for example psychopaths
are very good with this abstract
sympathy very bad with empathy they
don't actually feel the other person's
pain okay but they're very good at
manipulating people because they have
this kind of mentalizing and sympathy
where they can abstractly understand
people right and then people with autism
tend to be just the opposite so sorry so
so they they're not good at sympathy
they're not good at sympathy but they're
okay with effect sharing okay
interesting and this is I mean it's very
interesting the idea there are networks
in the brain that sort of do these
different functions are they quite
discrete and obviously separate I mean
is there some fixed number we're gonna
discover 20 years from now yes there are
35 networks in the brain that do these
sort of different emotional things or is
it kind of they blend into each other
you mean like empathic processing or are
we talking about just our generation
yeah yeah so okay so we talked about
mirror neurons but since the discovery
of mirror neurons a lot of different
kinds of shared circuits we call them
have been found so for example in this
amount of sensory areas so areas that
are active when I'm touched we find that
they're also active when I watch you
being touched okay we find that also
with discussed regions so regions that
are active when I feel disgusted when I
see you and experiencing disgust they're
also active I read that husband's have
these reactions when their wives are
pregnant they get
sort of fake pregnancies they get
morning that's interesting I haven't
heard it well so I say I heard of it I
literally watched it on Castle Rock last
night there is this TV show Stephen King
based TV show and honestly they were all
about mirror-neuron
this slightly crazy character was
convinced that her mirror neurons were
reaching out and touching other people
but they actually used that term oh yeah
they did yeah
and so I think that was an addendum that
was not in the original Stephen King
stories but they for him it was just
psychic powers but now it's mirror
neurons so maybe it's not true the
pregnancy I think I learned I shouldn't
trust you know Hulu originals as my
source material for psychological
insight but but it makes sense right
matter it is part of and it's adaptive
right understanding how other people are
feeling things but we don't go too far
right because we're not the same as them
right so you find actually for people in
the medical world they activate these
shared circuits for and for empathy
effect sharing much less than other
people I was gonna say
and also maybe like homicide detectives
right there's all these dead people and
they have any clinical and and cognitive
about it they can't feel like oh my god
this is a terrible tragedy right exactly
and so you know so for people who are
lacking empathy you probably want to
work on that but in the typical
population which you probably want to
focus your time working on is compassion
instead okay so you don't want people to
be stuck feeling someone's pain to the
point that they can't do anything about
it right right but you want them instead
to try to focus on compassion to
actually do something are there
generally therapeutic implications for
the kind of discoveries you make so you
know right now our work is focused on
autism uh-huh so we're trying to figure
out the difficulty with autism is that
there's so many different subtypes and
so we're working on different subtypes
of autism and trying to categorize them
so that we can focus interventions not
just everyone with autism gets to do
this one intervention but maybe if you
have this particular subtype this would
help you more I mean I know it's very
complicated and controversial and
it's you know I have friends with
autistic kids and it's very emotional
how would you just explain what autism
is to someone who didn't know what it
was yeah so autism is defined by a
deficit in social interaction so the
social piece of it not being able to
think about other people's emotions and
understand their intentions is probably
the biggest disorder in autism and then
there's also repetitive actions that are
made and also communication deficits so
it's something like you don't know when
other people are upset or you don't know
why they're upset or why they're happy
you don't get those ranges right right
so processing other people's social
information and this goes back to the
idea that one of the roles of the mirror
neurons is when we see somebody looking
happy or looking sad or whatever there's
something goes off in our brain that is
related to what happens when we're happy
and sad that helps us understand is that
exactly so this kind of simulating other
people from a neurological perspective
right right I seem to recall that in the
very earliest days a mirror neurons were
being talked about this connection with
autism was made and people pushed back
on it and other people hyped it up and
so what is the state of play right now
yeah so what we think is that autism is
very heterogeneous and there's probably
types of autism where mirror neurons are
more involved than other types and so
we're actually looking at autism that's
comorbid with dyspraxia dyspraxia is a
disorder developmental disorder of
coordination okay and a lot of kids with
autism have it so they're less
coordinated right but it's particularly
a motor deficit right and so since it's
a motor deficit we thought that maybe
these kids with autism who have
dyspraxia are more likely to have this
kind of broken mirror hypothesis if you
will okay and the data do seem to
support that and so the idea is that
maybe the reason some people find mirror
neurons
are less active in autism and other
people haven't is that autism is so
heterogeneous and you're not looking at
those same group yeah so someday again
in the future we'll realize there's
really 12 different things going on that
means that lump them all under the label
of autism it's so you're pretty
convinced that at least some of them
have a heavy involvement with not to say
that's the only thing going on right so
we do find a lot of other brain regions
that are also different in these kids
but that this might be one component
okay and does that have any therapeutic
implications like so we learned
something about where in the brain
something is happening but we're not
going to go in there and yeah poke it
with an electrode so what can we do yeah
so it's it's complicated so especially
given that this is just probably one
piece of the story but one kind of
therapy that has been done with kids
with autism with some success is called
imitation therapy where you teach kids
with autism to imitate and by imitating
they're not only working the motor
pathways that they need to but also
trying to understand the social
implications is it is it almost like
they're training their neurons to be
mirror neuron exactly oh yeah and so you
know this again needs to be further
tested but the idea is that maybe this
kind of therapy would be most effective
with these kids who have the additional
dyspraxia and maybe not it's not a
common therapy to just throw on every
kid with autism because the the
hypothesis is not that they lack the
mirror neurons but that the neurons in
their brain just aren't mirroring the
right way right they might not be
working the same way okay so that in
some sense it provides hope in the sense
that you can train them to do something
that maybe isn't automatic but I can
teach them right right my understanding
is a lot of autistic kids just at the
sort of crudest level trained themselves
to recognize and social cues and
emotional things on faces just in a kind
of rote way even if they don't if you
look themselves and this is it's very
abstract right so this is maybe a more
visceral version of that does that fair
exactly yeah that's the idea and
embodied version an embodied version yes
very good and beyond autistic kids so
yeah they're wider psychological so we
did a bunch of star studies on stroke
patients okay so after stroke
you know the main comment if you have a
motor impairment following stroke the
most common thing that you do is
physical therapy or occupational therapy
but the problem is there's only so many
hours a day you could do that and people
get tired right it's a lot of work yes
right and insurance companies only pay
for that for the first three months okay
and so one idea is if we know that
watching other people activates your own
motor system what about creating these
videos okay I have therapeutic things
that you're watching someone else do
right and you can think of it kind of
like homework you give it to some a
patient before they come into their PT
or ot and the night before and they're
watching these over and over again and
the brain is getting primed and so the
idea is that when they go to do that the
next day they should actually be better
right and so we do find some support for
that as well so when you have a stroke
is I know nothing about this is most of
the damage in your brain or is it
throughout your body no so stroke is
specific to the Pacific to the brain
yeah and is it's mostly physical damage
to the neurons or is it just whatever
wiring okay yeah
so in some sense physical lesion in the
brain okay so occupational physical
therapy you're you know stretching and
trying new motor skills right so you're
you're hoping that would rewire at the
brain but you're saying it is the brain
after all so we can you know help try to
rewire the brain and more directly brain
centered ways like well or you know by
thinking exactly right and if we we
believe in this embodied could knit
cognition then there's other ways to
activate these motor systems beyond just
moving right so into the body
do we try virtual reality virtual
reality could be very helpful it's a
little more difficult with people with
stroke because they can get dizzy and
fall down and you
right so you want to you want to be
careful when you do that um but you know
just having them watch these movies
seems to be pretty effective also okay
very good
and what about just people who don't
seem that empathetic what about people
who don't have an obvious physiological
issue but you mean like a psychopath
yeah or you know just you know couples
therapy you know someone is not okay
yeah so um you know the the most
comprehensive study of this being done
is actually being done by Tanya singers
lab and what she finds is she has people
do mindful meditation and different
kinds of mindful meditation for a
long-term I don't I don't know exactly
the details of how long they're doing it
for but she has them either do sympathy
okay
compassion training mindful meditation
it's something called loving-kindness
right mindful meditation or you know
some kind of control task right and what
she finds is that actually doing this
kind of meditation increases structural
changes in these networks in the brain
in the brain see the brain wiring itself
differently meditation exactly and also
functional changes and also behavioral
changes as well interesting I think that
people get a little bit scared or overly
impressed by the phrase you know
rewiring the brain like this rewires the
brain but in fact everything we do at
any moment in time is always rewiring
our brain right every memory we take is
every memory remember that's wiring or
acting so yeah so the interesting thing
for her is that she sees these in these
like either the compassion network or
the sympathy network or the empathy
network depending on which one you're
focusing on in your meditation I think
you've said this already but it's still
remarkable to me so we can take an fMRI
and see a place light up and go oh
that's the sympathy network mm-hmm right
so again the empathy network the emotion
resonance ones seems to be in these
emotion regions mirror neuron regions
and so
fourth the sympathy regions tend to be
prefrontal cortex temporoparietal
Junction and the pre cuneus it does
become harder and harder to be a
mind-body duelist when you see this part
of the brain is responsible for this
emotional reaction right right so yeah I
mean so there there are people who would
argue and I'm not sure they're wrong
that there is this embodied cognition
but the sympathy network might be
different than that and it might be more
abstract right it's complicated because
the prefrontal cortex also still gets a
lot of information from the body let's
do all these regions yeah right yeah my
default at this stage of scientific
progress is to think that we don't know
anything about neuroscience at all right
we have some good ideas and something
will turn out to be right but we have no
right to be confident in some ideas
versus others because right you say it's
really it's way more complicated than
physics way more complicated so actually
just to embody this even more one of the
things that we're now got some funding
to do is to add a microbiota component
okay
so explain what that means yeah so you
have these bacteria in your gut and they
actually interact with neurons in your
gut neurons in your gut yes and with
your different systems in the brain and
different systems in the body so your
immune systems and so forth and those
interact with the brain and so going
back to autism we know that a lot of
kids with autism have stomach problems
and it has been found that they also
have different microbiota than the
typical population and given that we
also know that the microbiota are now
interacting not directly indirectly with
either visceral neurons in the stomach
or through metabolites that can travel
to the brain they interact with the
brain so these microbiota then the
question is how does this all fit
together right so how do what's going on
in your stomach with these bacteria
interact with brain functioning and with
behavior so you're saying when people
the claims they make decisions with
their gut they might be literally doing
that exactly exactly
that's scary and I know some people like
that we I talked about this on a podcast
with Carl Zimmer the microbiome we have
all these microbes living in
approximately the same number of cells
in the microbiome as there are human
cells in our body and that gets back to
you know did I just just keep wanting to
go to these bigger philosophical
questions that's embodied cognition and
it kind of makes sense that our body is
important so one of the things that is
going to be a challenge when people try
to construct artificial intelligences is
that they don't have not just bodies but
the motivations that the body gives us
right hunger and sleepiness and things
like that are we learning about the
prospects for artificial intelligence by
studying embodied cognition I think
we're just mainly understanding how
complicated it would be to create a
system right and then especially when
you introduce you know the interaction
of the body with these like bacteria
right and so how is that influencing our
cognition and how we think and so forth
yeah I mean I think that um there are
books about uploading our brains right
into the matrix and just letting us let
us live in the simulated reality so that
will be basically your point is just
that's even harder than you think
cuz you don't have a body once you're up
there exactly and everything that goes
with it right I mean I've long wondered
I've long thought that it just wouldn't
be even if you could copy piece by piece
all of your neurons and all their
connections into the computer it
wouldn't be a copy of you exactly
because of these things because your
inputs are different and it's just it's
i mean maybe they'll be conscious maybe
it'll be intelligent but it won't have
the motivation difference it'll be
different it won't be it won't be you
yeah and yeah somehow it doesn't compass
immortality if you upload our brain in
that way right now unfortunately but
then there's also I forget what the word
is but there's the idea extended
cognition the idea that we use our
environment around us as part of our
cognitive
right that's more that's that goes
beyond embodied cognition right so that
the context of the situation right and
the environment that you're in also is
extremely important so if I take notes
you remember something I should count
that notepad as part of my cognitive
system that's right right do you think
this is a good idea well so that you
know there's that saying the medium is
larger than the message right yes that's
right so so in that sense yes right I
think I think definitely the environment
and non non biological systems are an
important part of our cognition
cognitive processes I mean certainly as
a physicist if I'm standing at the
blackboard writing some equations and
solving them you know in some sense I
can think of the blackboard in the chalk
is part of my cognitive system just like
my brain right but in some sense it's
clearly different right I mean so there
is there quasi philosophical or just
become a scientific question where is
the useful place to draw the
distinctions between these different
things right so there is actually these
neurons where if you work with a tool
long enough that tool becomes embedded
as part of your body representation okay
because we have a little we have these
maps in our brain of different parts of
our body and and so for example when
people have prostheses or even just a
cane right that can be mapped on by our
brain right exactly
and it actually doesn't even take that
long so in these monkey studies where
they're using a rake to reach for a
piece of food within a matter of minutes
that rake becomes part of their body
representation minutes yeah so how do we
know that is that dude that's actually
by looking at single electrodes by
single single that they're looking at
the you know the representation of the
reaching movement and then they start to
see that it it fills up to the periphery
to the you know to just where the rate
goes and this helps also explain things
like phantom limb syndrome phantom limb
is a little bit different so that's when
you lose a body part right
right but you feel like it's still there
and we think that that's more due to
rewiring where if you look at the
homunculus the body map in the brain in
somatosensory regions the for example
the face and the hand are very close
together okay okay so now if you've lost
a hand the face area takes over the
cortex that used to belong to the hand
okay and so now if you touch the face of
a person who's lost a hand they often
feel it in their phantom hand oh I see
okay right but that's because the cortex
just it's not gonna leave that real
estate alone it's gonna use it for
something else and the face was the
closest thing so it took it over free
CPU cycles as far as the brain is
concerned exactly right
interesting and does that have
implications when we do get into virtual
reality you know our virtual bodies so
like you know we can look different in
virtual reality than we do in regular
reality so if we have an avatar does our
avatar I mean it gets depends on the
quality of the virtual reality
experience but does our avatar get a map
a representation in the brain oh that's
an interesting question I don't know if
anyone's actually looked at that but I
could imagine that it could it could
happen yeah because usually you know
it's we pick avatars that are
better-looking versions of ourselves
right but I can imagine I have a cars
that look completely different different
numbers of arms and legs and I can
imagine a really good VR controllers
that would let us control all those
things separately right and I'm thinking
of like if you watch little kids playing
video games and they make the the Avatar
jump they actually jump themselves a
little bit right they do it a little hop
so this kind of embodiment right right
and I know one of the other things
you've worked on is related to this you
know how we relate to people different
than us right you know part of it of
course we see people like us it's the
same part of our brain reacting is when
we react ourselves as people become more
and more different differences in age or
ethnicity or gender or sickness or
whatever right does I meet harder to
yeah so okay so if you think about this
embodied cognition it's very easy to
understand why you would want to embody
and simulate people that you like and
people you want to be like and there's
actually you know the chameleon effect
in psychology where it's it's been found
over and over again that you implicitly
imitate people who are similar to you
and people you want to be like and
people you admire so if I'm having a
conversation with you and you lean
forward I lean forward yeah you you know
and it says this is all implicit we're
not thinking about called mirroring
right yeah it's also called the
chameleon effect okay okay and then we
do this less and less with people we
don't want to be like right so you don't
like someone you tend to just have less
of this chameleon effect so the question
that we wanted to ask in a bunch of our
studies was how do you then process
people who are very different from you
and perhaps the most dramatic difference
that you can have is having a different
body than someone else right so we
looked at a person who was born without
arms and legs and we were curious how
she processes body parts that she
doesn't have and how she understands
them so if you take the theory of
embodied cognition seriously you use
your body representations to understand
other people's bodies but if you don't
have those body representations Joanne
what do you do right right nothing for
your neurons to mirror right so we put
her in the scanner and we had her watch
different kinds of actions some actions
were possible for her even with a
different body part so for example
picking up a pen she does with her mouth
and something excuse me are completely
impossible for her so like going on
tiptoe or using scissors she can't do
that right and basically what we found
is that even for things that she can't
do she still tries to use her motor
representations to understand other
people but she for things that she are
impossible for her she additionally uses
these sympathy
regions okay so she's sort of offloading
that task to a different part of the
brain exactly exactly so she tries to
simulate it and when that doesn't work
she also uses the sympathy map regions
these mentalizing regions however she
has like a lifetime of experience
looking at people with full bodies right
and so we also did the opposite we
brought typical people watching her
residual limb doing actions so for us
that's a weird body part we don't often
see that right and what we found is that
when we get people more familiar with
her they start to see it as if it's a
hand or leg very you know it like a
normal body part but in the beginning
you see a lot of activity that's
different okay and so the idea is that
with more exposure to people who are
different from us then we start to see
them very similarly we normalize them in
some sense
exactly and we embody them very
similarly but in it it's a weird thing
because we're I mean is it I don't know
I won't say a worry but is it that we're
not treating them as they are we're
fitting them into a box meant for us and
they're really kind of different yeah so
in the beginning what we see when
they're not familiar with a person is a
lot of activity and visual areas so
they're using visual processing to
understand this person but not this kind
of more embodied processing and so the
idea is if we think that the embodied
processing is important right then we
would want to have that be similar to
watching other people right right and so
the more familiar we get them with a
person then the more of that they have
what about for animals can we do the
same thing for you know some centipedes
yeah okay so an interesting study was
when they brought in when they had a
human watch a monkey a dog or a human
make actions and they found that for all
of those if you were watching the
our animal eat you activated your mirror
neurons okay okay but it's common to
everything cuz that's common we can do
that but if it was something like the
human speaking versus the monkey making
vocalizations versus the dog barking you
would activate your mirror neuron system
for the first two but not for the dog
barking nothing barking yeah cuz that's
just so different
huh something we can't do but do you
think we could train ourselves yes so
that ladies have systems in their brains
that do you know track them yelling
things like that yes so I actually gave
a talk on this at Disney Animation and
people were shocked they were like what
do you mean we we know how to do that
and they started showing me how they can
actually barks exactly like a dogs Wow
but they're experts there exactly that's
right
but it probably still has its limits so
for example there is this theory about
the snake okay you've heard about this I
think it's an interesting theory so the
snake is the extreme other it was moves
in a way that we can probably never
replicate right right and so probably we
don't embody it the same way and so the
theory is that that's why in many
cultures around the world
the snake becomes either the deities or
other okay so yeah so these is powerful
cosmic figures are ones that don't map
onto our representations of our closet
what about isn't the octopus the extreme
other in some sense all right it has a
very different neural system that we
yeah that's true but it's less seen
right I mean how many times you see no
that's true but but have people thought
of putting the octopus in an fMRI but
you do also have like you know Ursula
from short right where it's also kind of
her eyes on her you know it's not a very
realistic representation and okay the
other thing I remember is that you've
also done work on creativity human
creativity and is this an outgrowth of
the work on embodied cognition or is it
no it's very separate actually
okay lay it on us what you thought about
so so this work is basically looking at
the interactions between the left
hemisphere and right hemisphere so
you've probably heard that the right
hemisphere is you know emotional
artistic hemisphere right that's what a
lot of people attribute to the right
hemisphere and the left hemisphere just
kind of sucks mathematical your verbal
but if someone asked you are you afraid
hemisphere left hemisphere person you
would rather say you're right you right
that's the cool yes the nerdy hemisphere
and the cool right exactly right so
however so it's so in popular culture
the right hemisphere is your creative
brain right however in the 70s Joe bogan
had this theory that creativity comes
not just from the right hemisphere but
an interaction between left hemisphere
processing which is this more serial
more localized more fast processing and
so an interaction between the left
hemisphere with the right hemisphere
which is this more visual spatial this
more drawn out long term processing gist
alt processing and it's that interaction
of having both of those processing going
on at the same time that leads to
creativity not just one versus another
that makes sense so we did a series of
studies to test that and basically we
supported that hypothesis I mean how
much does that help us understand where
ideas come from right inside for okay
it's an interaction between things is
there something about that interaction
that we can pinpoint yeah I mean that's
the more difficult question right so we
do know from a bunch of psychology
studies that you know thinking about a
problem from different perspectives is
really important thinking about a
problem for a long time with a lot of
focus and then taking a break okay is
really important right they can we
tribute that or subconscious is still
chugging along
exactly and we know that the aha moment
these kinds of creative creative moments
come from a lot of subconscious
processing so oftentimes when you're
doing this non creative processing
you'll know exactly where you are in the
problem solving you'll say I need five
more minutes and then I'll have the
answer
whereas with these creative aha moments
someone will ask you how close are you
to the solution and you'll say I have no
idea
wait a second oh my god right and so
yeah it's a lot of it's a lot more of
this unconscious processing along with
the conscious processing so do people
from Silicon Valley come and ask your
advice on how to I mean we we have some
steps that like when I teach a class and
we do like this workshop on creative
ways to solve problems but no no one
from Silicon Valley need a better agent
probably all right so to sort of wrap
things up what do you let's let's think
about the broader picture here I mean I
have casually said you know neuroscience
is still in a state where we're not
really sure about anything so but but
you're the expert what what do you think
about our current understanding of how
the brain works and how it connects to
the body overall and the prospects you
know how long will it take before we
really nail some of these things down
and what is what is most exciting things
that we should be looking forward to in
the future yeah I mean I think what it
means by what you mean by nailing it
down I think we're getting closer and
closer to understanding enough to be
able to help people in different
situations understanding enough to know
what kinds of cognitive processing are
useful mm-hmm and helpful to society and
the self versus ones that are probably
not I mean that's pretty good
that's pretty good right I think you
know the goal for any neuroscientist is
to have a comprehensive understanding of
the brain I think we're a long way off
of that
but you know I don't know if that's
absolutely necessary to do all the other
stuff that we need to do to just help
move society forward right and to help
people with problems get better there is
the human brain initiative right and
that's just is that mostly concerned
with mapping the connections between the
neurons yes for the most part it is
which is not what we really do like
would it even be helpful for you to have
such a map without an understanding of
the algorithm right it's difficult to do
much without it I think knowing the
algorithm is more important than the map
I've heard people analogize it to like
it's literally like having a map of the
city but not knowing why anyone is going
down a road you don't understand the
economic life of the city right it's
sure I mean it's good knowledge to have
right so it's like yeah just like the
the DNA sequence is good to know right
but it's not enough yeah oh there are
tools that are better than fMRI that are
hopefully coming down the pike yeah I
mean so the MRI has its limits so you
can't move your head while you're inside
okay
that's a huge limit um it's loud and
scary for some people right if you have
any kind of metallic thing in your body
you can't do it so is there anything
better not not not yet what do you think
about brain computer interfaces yeah I
mean I think they're great for people
who you know have lost parts of their
body and who need some kind of
prosthetic to do something for them I
think they're amazing
um are you thinking about like robot
soldiers and stuff no I'm thinking about
implants into our heads that will let us
access our emails without a smartphone
oh that's what I want to have someday
you want to have I do really I think
it's kind of inevitable so I'm you know
just planning most people are hoping to
ways to unplug well I would hope they'll
be able to unplug I guess maybe that's
the downside like what if what if
there's no off switch to it right every
single like advertisement come yeah I
know that there are companies now that
will you know put a gear on your head a
rig right
we'll try to read some of the activity
in your brain it's very crude because
it's outside your skull there's a big
layer in between and that's a long way
I'm not trying to you know give the
impression that I overhyped the idea of
literally implanting something into your
skull that sounds much harder maybe
it'll never work well but they do they
are starting to do that with people who
have prosthetics right uh-huh I don't
know yeah yeah so that's it is being
done and that's a very good reason to do
it for downloading email I'm not sure
that's right there's so much bacteria
you can get but this also I mean the
work that you're doing in embodied
cognition is that going to be helpful to
that kind of thing if you're really I
mean at some level someday we'll try to
presumably if you have prosthetics you
want to make them more and more like
parts of your body mm-hmm right and
ideally you'll have sensory signals that
are going to your brain so you can
embody that right right yeah so I think
that having that kind of system where
you also are getting feedback from the
prosthetic is also going to be very
important it seems like it's there's
gonna be I remember physicist so I still
like physics but there's a lot of
exciting things going on in neuroscience
yeah the year-by-year changes are quite
impressive yeah I would agree and you
know it's kind of nice because I think
as a physicist you're also feeling this
but there's part of neuroscience that's
becoming kind of like a humanity right
which is very philosophical and you know
interacting with linguistics and with
psychology and with with people
processing right and I think there's
parts of physics that have become like
this as well and it's it's beautiful to
be in a field like that I totally agree
and I was I was trying to refrain from
asking you to define consciousness or
anything like that that's not your thing
right yeah I thought not so much but and
it's I mean that's a whole other hour
right many working neuro scientists I
think that people on the street maybe
get the misimpression that that's what
neuroscientists do they sit around
arguing about what consciousness is but
there's a lot still to be done in what
Chalmers called the easy problem of
consciousness right which is like just
how the brain gets through the day
forget it
you know thinking of itself and getting
experiences of the redness of red but
you know how we see things and react to
them and that's probably part of where
the embodied cognition paradigm is
trying to figure things out yes I think
so
all right Lee says these a day thank you
so much for thank you thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]